.
REPUBLIC
WITHOUT TRUMBEG IT
BUSISS WHISHARY 6tE
JUSTTEOME REPUBLICANISHEBIUG
HOMES WITHO --
LOST T THAT DAY,
UMERE TAKING
TH O
>>
LESCHNEIDER.
ATTOEY SOME  GRILLING THEME TOD
ED INTOUR DING, BUT IT
PARTISTING
FORMERINE SEY D NG WHILEEPUBLI
PAUL
FUOATED CTT
HEARD FRW CL NOT AINSURRECTION E
N  DERLY IOHE L JUSTING VIDEOS .
SAW UNFOLD.R F WE
ALL OF THIS ISLLS
FROMERAL MEMBERS OTHCOMMITTEE
THINGS GOT PCUY FIJANUARY 6th.
WHEN DEMOCUET
E FORMER ACTINFECRARS  SPONSEHE
ER FOREEMINGBACKMM
THAT FORMEPRESIDENTRCOMMENTS AR
CAPITOL ATTACK.
>> THERE WERE 8,000 BADGNDTICE
MR. CR YOU WEREN'TREYOU WERE AWO
INACCURATE.
IST YOU WANT B YVE RESPONSIBILI
SOMETHING GOES WRONG IT LY, . P
>> RH FOR YOURORIS MORNING -VE
ENCOURAGED THES
DAY. MENT.
>> SO THIS IS
HERE'S DIFFE
AVERSALF
YOUR TESTIMONY.
THAT'SIDICULOUS.
>> Reporter: THAT EXCHANGE W
YSCRY MILLERAID INEMARKS, AND
INVESTIGN INTO THE PEOPLE
THAT DAY, IT H
A ANPONTANEOUS ATTACK
THR'S DETHE.A
OA HIS
ACTION A PARTMENT'S RNS UNDERSTS
MILITARY WOULD APPRECIATE THEY
OBVIOULE THE S
MEANTIME THAT NAON
TROOPS DIDN'T ARRIVE UNTIL AFT5O
AND REPUBLICANS WHEN IS TOWHAT
GUYS?> A LO HEAOT
ENOUGH LIGHT.
CHENEYAS EPURRS U
LONGER.
ANY ELSEEY
OE S
VO
ARE , DURINGS VERY SHO
MEETING, WHICH CAMR WEEK
OF D SURROUNDING HER FUT GOT UP
PEOPLE WHOTEER VED FRT POST AS H
H,S PREET S PRETTYEE. CASE,EVIN
YH
EYDE, BASICALLY A GRTHEYVO
WITH CHENEY, SOMEONE WHO HAS
CALLED OUTPECIFIY FORM
PRESIDDOAND THEY SEEM POIS TO RC
RIGHT NOW SHE'THE ONLY COERHAIRW
SHE OMERBE  UNIFY THE PARTY.
SHE DIDN'T SPECIFICALLY GET TH2T
FUTURE AND WHAT IS XT FORLICAN
O IGNORED S TEST FOR
REICT  LOY
XTSI WHAT HE IS T
THE FORMER PRESIDENT
L THEY FOR T
CTOR A ALI
RYANOBOU VERY
MUCH.
DAVID CHALIAN ISERMIKE ROGERS,
5/12/21.
ITVET TO
GRANDCHILDRE
GREAT-GRANDCHILDREWIS ANOTHER ME
BRI DO TE
.
I THINK THRE WILE
WHETHER THIS IS JUST LIZ CHENEEN
BEING SMALD AND DEMOCRACANE
DE FOR A
PERSONAL DTRP.THAT WILL CAREEN O
AND PERHAPS INTO I DEMIS
EVALS AN P BOOKS -- AGAINI N'
KNOW TT W TH,
THE TRUTH  OWN PARTY
ANTHE PARTTORE
AGGREIVWANTD ITSELF TO . LIZHEA
YOU CAN'T SUPPORT THE BIG LIE
ANE CONSTITUTION.
, THAT THE NGS ARE AIT
LL DO
I ON
OOE MORNING,
BICKIN AFTERR  A
INOUO MI
LEADER KY HERE.ELY AFTE ETING AI
NEXT NFANBIG LIE.LET'S LISTEN.
>> WELL, FIRSTF ALL, THE
CONFERENCE WILCIBUT I DO
QUESTIONING THE LEMA
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIOI THINK.
WE'RE ESENDAY.
THCONFERENCE SFERENCE OR HE
N TO WHAT WE HAV
FAR TOD?TES IS NOT A
ACT TOGEER. BLINDT GNGVET
FOR TRUM UNDOING
HE WILL T BEHE INTO -- AFTER T B
ELECTION.
URICANS'
REGAINHEGROUND
ON THING
PRINCI OE  LME
ERT  OUT CRVATIVCIPLES, FISCAL C
HODN
EVERY D
OS EED HAPPENING WITH
D.
WE HTOACK TO
I THITL CR